Joey what's up yo going it's going
alright how's it going with you I'm
going great and you're here so bring a
lot better so that makes it really great
exactly please so you're an actor yeah
scripted screaming into Big Brother
unscripted
right why they don't know I'm still
trying to figure it out to be honest
with you no you know it's just larger
conversations you know and bigger
pictures and it's all about that stuff
but no CBS and I've been talking about a
lot of stuff and you know they asked me
to do this and you know and then ask me
again and you know it's just I'm here so
that's it
have you seen any bits of the show at
all uh I I had never watched it yeah and
I when I said okay
just you know I watched like a couple
episodes of The Celebrity Big Brother
last year yeah other than that no
honestly I I actually loved it better
when people kind of go in a little bit
blindly it's more fun to watch is it
well I'll be a lot of fun there yeah
there's more fun to watch people were
just like going for the first time and
you know and experiencing that for the
first time without having any kind of
like preconceived I have a ton of
preconceived notions but I have no skill
level yeah great I'm thinking that yeah
it's been yeah I don't really know
anything other than that you know you're
gonna go in there and some people are
gonna like you and some people aren't
that's all you know that's it that's
what I told you it's pretty much it no I
know Joey you and shrub that much you in
trouble okay so you're touching up a
little tiny bit do you have all the big
brother Ling goes down at least uh no I
mean H what you head of household Joe H
there is POV pob I don't know what that
is what about that point of view that's
right that's what I can see why you
would think when I view is that what is
in script its power of veto power veto
yes now I know these hits have a point
for that just so you guys know and how
about backdoor I know what that means in
the real world I'm not sure what that
means in the Big Brother house well is
it good in the real world it could be
depends you know for all personal
preference I guess but you know
backdoor means what in the Big Brother
house what is it and the Brother house
it's never good a personal preference or
not is never good okay okay you don't
want to be back doored okay ever okay
okay so just take that with you knock it
right here all right and off you go okay
do it yeah you got it what's your
strategy for going into the house um
honestly you know I I think I don't
really have one other than that it's
some sometimes you can you know sort of
react as a strategy and sometimes you
can be like proactive right so for me
because I don't really know a lot about
it it has to be more of a reactive sort
of game plan you know and what happens
in there I have to sort of see how it
works and see who I'm dealing with and
you know and we'll take it from there
but I'm not a I'm not a you know I'm not
like a guy I'm not a divisive guy I'm
not an alliance guy you know so you're
so low I mean they're you know hanging
out uh-huh
hopefully there'll be some nice people
in there and hopefully some people you
know will will think I'm okay and I'm
sure others won't and that's okay I'm
I'm cool with this because you're going
in and you're not being proactive you're
being reactive how are those like how
like how do you react to things like
confrontation how do you react to that
um Joey I hate you yeah I'm sorry you
feel that way when you do about it
not much because we're trapped in a
house together so Joey you're going on
the block oh that's unfortunate
hopefully I'll make it through you're
going home actually I'm thrilled that's
the guy I'd be like great that's cool
I mean it was Bob and I'm happy I'm here
I'm glad you know I'm happy for the
opportunity it's been fun hanging out
with you guys for a few days but you're
gonna be that nice yeah why wouldn't you
be I mean there's no reason not to be I
don't know these people
yeah honestly at the end of the day
we're playing a game right yeah people
are really doing really important stuff
throughout this world right I mean like
major things going on we got troops
everywhere like protecting us I'll kill
you let's go play silly games but when
you're in the house that becomes your
world cuz I've been there before
you've been an hour been in that house
before you've been in I've been in the
house and I'm telling you right now a
little I know about it were you a
contestant yes wow fant I don't even how
did you feel about your experience there
I'll say when you're
that is your world and y'all thinking
about troops you're not thinking about
you're thinking about surviving in that
world always thinking about our troops
you know what you're always but he's a
nice good but i but i but i will be
competitive at all I'm competitive in
nature but not to the point of
foolishness
you know I'm competitive when I know it
really means something you seem very
level-headed it's not something I like
to watch I like to see the ones go crazy
I'm sure you'll have plenty of it with
plenty of crazy are you the one who will
like Custer the crazy or you just the
one who will sit back and eat popcorn
and watch oh I'm gonna watch your watch
the crazy go down yeah that's what I
plan on doing sure first HOH want to win
it or no um you know maybe I mean it'd
be you know it's like if you win it's
cool right although I don't really even
know if I want to move on my crap to
another place you know yeah you have to
move your stuff somewhere else to move
your stuff somewhere else is overrated
too much work for you I mean it's just
think I don't know once it's sitting
over there it's just I'm like my thing
it's organized you know I don't know if
I really want to move maybe I'll give it
to somebody else
I don't know you but I'd like to win it
so you want to win but but but you but
I'm thinking you could say to someone if
you're in a competition you're the last
two remaining you know what just take it
keep me safe
don't leave my stuff where they are yeah
that sounds great right yeah you could
just you could use that that could be a
stretch I think so are you something
like that I I personally would not how
far did you get
Final Four really yeah I didn't win so I
mean my word isn't you come in second no
I didn't come in super bonus for second
there is a bonus and there is a bonus
for first right and a bigger one for
first yeah yeah um I want I want you to
aim for first well second place is first
loser so it's either first or bust
that's for sure yes yes so for me unless
I can win it every day that I survived
that I don't win I'm actually paying
them you know giving more than my time
for not anymore
you know so you know it's just what you
think about things you seem really chill
easygoing go with the flow kind of a
person if I watch this show right and I
see someone completely different
bs maybe you like this guy was so full
of you know what no no I'm pretty I mean
you know what I can get amped up if I
need to
yeah but I don't like to dwell in that
space because that's a waste of time you
know how do you handle nerves because
you're gonna be an in constant nerves I
would think because then competition
you're you're nervous you're excited and
then a POV not point of view right the
power eat up your your nerves want to
win that again right and the veto is
exactly
and then there's always evictions and
there's always things happening and
you're always like nervous when it comes
to these things how do you handle your
nerves clean do you cook you cook sure
cook yeah I yeah I requested a keyboard
in there so I think they're gonna put
some music in there look at you getting
things I don't know I mean I asked my
Begum I think we get something because
there's no music or anything in there
right now music alright all yeah you
don't really see outside that much you
know you don't kind of a weird thing
that you volunteered to put yourself in
I know I got that's that's the part that
I'm really questioning your so much it's
more an internal reflection yeah what's
happening it's okay
honestly you're having a great time it's
a lot of fun I'm telling you from
experience it's it's fun okay I probably
want it to be fun yeah they were both
[ __ ] it'll be fun well you seem good
yeah
you don't seem negative at all you like
yeah and if you don't have that sort of
personality where you're looking for the
best in things you want to have fun yeah
you're gonna have okay okay okay I'll
take that day um it's on the show though
yeah I want to see a more energetic Joey
energetic Joey I'm more energetic when
okay all right I gonna see that maybe
depends I mean that you know I can be
energetic I'm actually very energetic I
just bubbling to the surface you know I
call it what I need to really sure right
now we'll see what happens I mean at the
end of the day it's this is all fun and
games you know so I don't you know it's
soft fun and games till you lose that eh
awaiting on the block yeah yeah but then
if the block happens you know then what
then you're up and maybe they may maybe
it's a popularity contest at that point
maybe they feel
and they want you off at that point
maybe they just don't like you and they
want to at that point and if that's your
destiny then you're out but the
intention is always to go in there and
win
you